where here's some breathing hi friend
could you please tell me where the
thieves went hi friend
alright let's go rose
welcome to dreadout act 2 is out we're
gonna check it out boom bada bing bada
boom it's gonna be a [ __ ] amazing I
don't really remember we the the first
one ended kind of abruptly with this
lady just being all that and that's all
I remember
but here we are in them a kowai Oh a
search of unknown power is radiating
from the collected items that has to be
good look at my kawaii tits I mean look
at my kawaii face and my body
I got my bag I got my shoes yeah ready
to go and have a great time I heard
something
oh alright well that sounded like a
demon from hell hello what was that
don't think I don't hear you oh yeah I'm
just a lonely girl don't hurt me
alright then I just need a lot love him
what was that what is that sound hey
girl what's that sound everybody think
the dumb one now alright we can't seem
to go in there you need to ain't
interesting Oh God hello I hear
something over here I swear to God what
the [ __ ] are you you tiny little Smurf
people he [ __ ] Smurfs so many Smurfs
I've never seen this made Smurfs in my
life this is I thought eyes it's [ __ ]
my leg
I mean it's hump whatever I'm taking
pictures of it [ __ ]
Smurfs aren't real you're gonna look so
ugly on Facebook you have no idea
ah I'll kill you you're not gonna look
bad on Facebook you're gonna look better
Twitter hey stupid idiots what the [ __ ]
are you my framerate just went down to
[ __ ] it's biting me what a dick
oh my god they're [ __ ] me hard man
sob sob
stop smurf sound real Smurfs aren't real
Smurfs are ah [ __ ] they're real and it
hurts
that was [ __ ] Smurfs it is smooth
purse oh and get a life I don't know if
I'm doing anything right here I'm doing
a lot hey that's my cell phone [ __ ]
they took my Sunita crazy L food phone
what a dick and my purse
they're so over they're so sexy but do
you think there's how I I mean I can't
be the only one alright they running the
speed and [ __ ] light - that's cool
I got sad I look now well like the home
they took my phone oh okay I have a new
object in them to get back our phone I
guess well we can go here now that's
kind of cool
where here's I'm breathing hi friend
could you please tell me where the
thieves went hi friend alright I never
made bitch-slap so hard in my life
what the [ __ ] man mate stop mate I'm
running it's [ __ ] crazy stop that
stop that at once I'm gonna go inside
here yes battle ok duster
oh you're a [ __ ] now [ __ ] whoa oh [ __ ]
nothing oh wow he wrecked me stop
wrecking me
oh god I'm wrecking [ __ ] as [ __ ] man I
came in like an Indonesian man I never
[ __ ] heard man all I want it we lost
him yeah I think we lost him
cool good time seeing the nation man
good times
Indonesian it's you still after me let's
just go here I'll go here I don't know
it ah boxes he scared me
stop it boxes Oh box you flow like
[ __ ] look how they fly let's try
fly garbage fly garbage went to space I
love you garbage what Warren the space
King 1 the space King about the
Indonesians that's crazy send some
offers I feel like we should go back in
but I'm not sure if it says off I came
in like an oh wow
hey pretty you can't touch my booty B
you can't touch my body and you nobody
touches my booty
you want to touch my titty so close but
yet so far you really want them titties
[ __ ] idiot you're a real jerk you
jerk you know that
I'm gonna go to that where we were
before [ __ ] that
what an idiot what a mean person alright
kick the garbage bags kick in become
real good oh it's a DJ booth wreck
America pretty pad that's pretty good
hey bucket how you doing so I was
supposed to go there huh unless there's
something here that I missed oh great I
just wasted a bunch of times and walking
[ __ ]
well what are you gonna do if you're not
gonna [ __ ] you might as well
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you know Luke's a
good girl ok that's the face of someone
who's just fine they're just fine so far
I love this act is my favorite act in
the whole world oh boy it's so much hey
they have their pots here that's great a
taxi
cold parking it looks like we're gonna
have to walk past this as a whole I love
it so much
yes here we go Wow
nice right umbrella power [ __ ] now I'm
gonna use this to smack those little
Smurfs yeah that's right ha ha
that's right Smurfs you better [ __ ] with
me if you want to [ __ ] with my own foam
that's right kill the Smurf an apple
sorry I have a problem it's a condition
smack dad Bam Bam bit oh look at that
moon it looks very texturized I like it
someone's like I can eat it Oh God is
that a reference to a like clock tower
isn't it you know the guy with a sister
yeah you're too young it's all right
but Birds I know what you mean shut shut
up hey I found a Jenga lot I found it
Jang was very sexy Jeng Jeng what I love
Jenga lights they're my favorite
Jenga lots are great they are so great
hey video cameras yeah it's like a
studio sent here hello there dead man
don't mind if I do dead man don't mind
if I do
more cameras shut up bird you don't know
me
[ __ ] so weird as noises there's no bus
like this in Indonesia I know I have a
lot of indonesian bros out there but
it's a is this all god oh no it's it
[ __ ] again smack it with the umbrella
oh no what above boner-killer
well I'm glad we use the umbrellas so
delay went Li what the what well that's
pretty smart well well
look I know my feet is he gonna find me
he's not God I'll better crawl then
hello Peppa Peppa dear
I love crawling in Indonesia and [ __ ] Oh
God
that was a close one and they just
[ __ ] with the umbrella I feel like I
can [ __ ] with umbrella can I just [ __ ]
my umbrella I felt like I could become
mother brother
ah it's pretty good so far
I enjoyed this I did this a lot do you
Bryce cool look at that side boob I have
a problem alright Jesus
I fell down Oh God smack him with a bra
you're probably better off upstairs
honestly theta4 is this shitty oh oh I
should jump down and [ __ ] him up oh no
it's the selfie ugly [ __ ] Miley Cyrus
stop taking selfies with my phone oh my
god she's such a [ __ ]
she literally became a wrecking ball
oh god oh god don't touch me peasant I'm
a beautiful woman no one touches me
that's right I nailed it you really fall
on everything no Jade Jesus Christ oh my
god so does he what is this a falling
montage he must be dead now no he's oh
oh well that's how I wake up in the
morning - how relatable what the [ __ ] is
this
there's so many cutscenes so kawaii I
better just stand here I mean I better
run a mushroom oh god oh god where do I
go oh my god
[ __ ] brah we gotta make it a tram
thing oh god he's gonna get me now oh he
hit me right up
hey stop here's some mean
oh he's steamin is slapping me that's
not very nice
you're a [ __ ] oh well you is the one
one ugly-ass [ __ ] Oh kinky I
like it I like this demon very kinky
what you gonna do now spirit
No
now as her friend
well you better get a move-on girl maybe
get another umbrella or some [ __ ]
we're fine girls and Bruce what all
right we're good
let's party hard jiggle ideas to the
other side
ah he he just gonna this is gonna go
really slowly just because I'm so sad so
sad a lot of dead people here scum nice
hey is that a head but that mutt [ __ ] is
that another one somebody dead people
what happened here
people need to be less dead in this
place that'd be great
I'll write this place nine out of ten on
IGN but that's a little bit too many
dead people yeah that joke is not
overuse Oh
are we gonna switch character now no
alright well hey dead people I take it
back touch me passing that's right
you know why I am oh she touched me
that's that's lovely
don't ever do that again and I'll cut
your hand up a DSLR camera that's proof
and the battery is still working
Wow now this [ __ ] Smurfs man I swear
to god was I get a hold of the Smurfs
SLR oh you use [ __ ] Smurfs he figure
it back my purse in my cellphone I got
my bag back that's right
in my bag why who's doing it oh my
[ __ ] [ __ ]
I was not born for this I am taking you
you're gonna look so good a no man so
all these angles are there what they're
working for your girl may you oh that's
your penis
alright cool that's that's great oh you
looking great buddy oh you look so good
oh my god you're gonna be on the
magazine cover
you're gonna be on Britney Spears new
website please don't touch me please
further oh my god we did it I can't
[ __ ] believe we did it
that ugly son of a [ __ ] died we find my
bag and now I'm fast
oh we defeat The Smurfs Smurfs ain't a
[ __ ] I'm a this [ __ ] [ __ ]
break it down to me now Smurf now
perched sorry I'm really beatboxing mood
another cutscene perhaps I'd be great -
hello cutscenes please give me more
cutscenes a glitch on Linda's camera
indicates that the enemy is within
firing range interest in through in
tracing in interesting don't be afraid
open doors
thanks game alright we went through this
cop and we're now outside and it's like
it's pretty good time
pretty relatable good old time I am now
stuck I'm fine
oh we wake up in the morning we did it
hi moon
you're still there though it's kind of
just me Zelda feels when you walk in the
mountains that's [ __ ] weird hey what
the [ __ ] is this a naked ladies hello
thumbnail alright well hey I'll take it
are they naked aha damnit what the [ __ ]
so what are you guys really doing here
that's right I take all your picture my
Instagram feed is gonna blow up after
this [ __ ] oh oh oh of course yes yes yes
yes yes yes that makes so much sense it
almost hurts hello house that's everyone
doing here well I'm glad we're enjoying
yourself this is this is quite amazing
Indonesia what the actual [ __ ] happened
to you alright well I appreciate ladies
but I got got a I don't know what I got
anyway I should probably just get the
[ __ ] out hey a kitty
how you doing kitty that's right kitty
don't block my way kitty I swear to god
kitty
alright so we had a good time not
cheating at all this is taking pictures
of that naked woman not naked woman she
should be naked let's be honest here
come on it's a horror game just put some
[ __ ] titties in there already
there you go you have to press the F
button that's [ __ ] the dumbest [ __ ]
what that didn't even make any sense I
figured that out by myself all by my so
BAM took a picture of all the ugly
[ __ ] and now we can progress oh
yeah that's right I say that's right
your foot sorry I shouldn't yell these
things out loud it's not his turn yet is
it I think it's the this guy's turn next
good times feeling good on a Wednesday
yeah yeah that Bo day is going to be
okay no it still don't get anything but
I think I took a picture of all of them
so yeah you're all going in my
collection don't worry don't you worry
all right so the puzzles in this region
is really [ __ ] hard all right I'm not
a genius no one thinks I'm a genius but
as you can see the wings align kind of
so you have to take a pic surprise
surprise
I'm almost out of camera [ __ ] oh my
god this is gonna be a [ __ ] nightmare
to edit oh my god all right for the
seven millions interruption in this
we're not even getting started all right
you're supposed to
I knew this because I'm smart in general
how do I supposed to line them that
looks great
what about the DSLR that looks oh [ __ ]
it I'm a cat Ibuka I don't think you
liked it oh oh that is creepy yes whoa
hello oh my god there were demons
weren't they giant breasted lady aw damn
it i interested lady you were too good
to be true
hello don't hurt me I'm Swedish we have
feelings
Oh last no it's [ __ ] creepy as [ __ ]
stop I know you're there
oh god what the [ __ ] is that oh we did
it we project project prod [ __ ]
oh god this is scary me this is not good
I don't like being scared no y'all know
I gotta like Otto don't hurt me a giant
person lady please show me the baby
giant person lady I follow wherever you
will want me to go I love you so so so
much not because of your giant breasts
because you have your personality of
course what's happening down hurt ah
[ __ ] is your problem let's look through
everything I took a picture there it is
oh you [ __ ] you ugly oh my god I'm so
glad I didn't vote about this
what the [ __ ] Ibaka Tomoka what the
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you that's right I
take pictures of your ugly i yeah don't
touch me I'm famous alright don't do it
and that's right Briggs oh god oh god oh
god what just happened why did it go oh
my god this is the best bottle nice no
shame on you for being ugly
shame on you ugly peasants you'll be on
the next cover of Vogue and everyone
will laugh everyone will laugh see
you're not supposed to walk in stop
alright this is not [ __ ] cool son
[ __ ] Nicole how about that
so did your triple kill [ __ ] oh god one
got me that's not good
this is very bad this is very very very
very not good
triple kill Oh God
you you know the sleeping bags or
whatever it looks like they're running
in one of those I shouldn't use this
camera I'll use my phone oh god what
there you're you is an ugly [ __ ]
aren't you oh my god don't come near me
you ugly [ __ ] oh god now I'm dead
that's right I took a picture of your
ugly I I took a picture in your bad
angle Oh God not this sleep second take
some of that no makeup hashtag no makeup
[ __ ]
that's right [ __ ] all right give me
this sack potato man give me them
boom-boom-boom-boom more pictures they
have cycles sickles whatever ah not fair
now it's [ __ ] cool
now [ __ ] call not [ __ ] coal
what the [ __ ] didn't work after a while
I got to wait a little bit I guess
how many shots do they take literally
yeah you either dead [ __ ]
you is a date well doing good brothers
proud of myself
I mean you ugly angle ugly angle you
look ugly as [ __ ] my god you're ugly
that's right everyone's gonna know about
it [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I should have said that
what happened
but I did something wrong now we're fine
she says ugly as [ __ ]
see why my video I'm clicking see I
can't do anything
okay so that's [ __ ] weird if you
don't press any buttons you win so I
guess it's like yeah thanks for not
taking any more of those ugly pictures I
guess I'll let you live what a weird
message today's society is spreading
interesting while we handle that like a
mouse now where do we go in Party
oh so many dead people in this pit
that's kind of nice oh it's oh it's you
it's it's you don't like her at all
ah what is happening
more boss battle I thought we were
through maybe my cell phone Oh night
alright so this game is very
unconventional first of all in a
QuickTime event
you're not supposed to click anything
and then in a boss battle you're
supposed to die great great to date it's
[ __ ] weird it's really [ __ ] weird
alright this shut up shut up you don't
know [ __ ] I'm going through the curtains
of light my favourite curtains they're
so soft like a titty so soft thank you
good times
well this is [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] to
play this game it's I remember it was
the same same in the first one you had
to find like this one key by pressing e
at this one spa random spot and that's
like the only way to progress and you're
like how the [ __ ] is anyone supposed to
do that oh we wake up here now wake up
in the morning feeling like a red lady
killed me your temps I hope this will be
a bit more straightforward like in the
beginning because getting stuck is not
fun I hear ladies crying or laughing I
don't care I hear something
oh you creepy ass [ __ ]
let's try go and [ __ ] yourself cool oh
no I want to read it
Pam bong Carol maqam hamanaka Bobby
Bobby Lovato - yeah all right
nailed it that's how we do that means
old lady crying over her selfies not
being pretty I figured I would say I
mean why else would she die from one hey
this is nice
I can dig how's everyone doing here
let's see here
Oh sonic can say hiya sekolah cool
anymore crying lady how's it going how's
everyone doing
hello hello hello
Oh cutscene love cutscenes Oh a crying
potato
don't cry potato I love you is that one
of our friends it is
that's cute I don't even know they died
I I don't I don't talk so don't talk to
me please
I think we played this in the demo then
we at the very end of it
Oh Oh
set the teacher oh oh alright then
alright it's alright with me huh
how you doing day huh are you doing huh
how you don't now as everyone don't
worry
now you don't worry are you doing you're
doing good doing good girl you don't do
it
you don't you don't do you don't go to
white well I understand you're doing
you're doing good
hey yeah Beth hi do I have to talk to
them cuz I don't like talking oh [ __ ]
I'm I'm fine I'm fine
alright she's crying who do you think I
am turn they break it move it shake it
though that I think hey yeah yeah
I guess I'm gonna follow her don't go
without me please I love you love you
baby don't go without me
I just want to see you pee on me no wait
what the [ __ ] did I just more crying
[ __ ] where is she yes yes that's
right you're gone now
idiot
you're really creepy could you stop
Thanks Thanks I love how she runs it's
it's a mixture of running his skiing
which is my favorite type of running yes
I would run in Sweden it said don't be
afraid open doors and I seem completely
unable to all right that's a cute doll
you look like a [ __ ] idiot what do
you you want me to say
that's it you know I'm gonna post this
on your Facebook and everyone's gonna be
like who the [ __ ] all right you know
what [ __ ] it really this is our dead end
alright we're alone now tell me why are
you holding that I'm just gonna sit then
oh really
[ __ ] really that's a douchebag move
you know
I was just heading back to my plate to
pick some stuff up and I said you
following me so okay that looks like
Linda hi Linda oh my gosh and you should
totally play a game or something I
haven't see tag I spy rock paper
scissors
it's something burning around here you
know holy crap Linda you look like a hot
mess
have you been up to Who am I kidding
same old crazy busybody Linda I'm always
gonna be checking on everyone and
everything all the time
that's my name don't wear it out
but have you met Susie yet no no she's
not a doll you're making Susie angry no
no what just happened Oh
uh-huh let me show you a trick
ah
oh cool cool trick love it
audit llama along its Amal arch alright
well that was a great part one don't you
think I think we accomplished quite a
lot alpha enjoyed a plank me we find a
mention key how about that see in the
next one leave a like if you enjoyed in
one part too and I will make sure to
give it to your girl boy whatever
dinosaur